welcome back Chris thanks for calling in
oh you got it let's get right into it
let's jump right into any Steph Curry
hurt Chris I'm gonna have to take him by
his worry obviously doesn't look right
I've asked tulipe Lee is there anything
going on he said Chris I'm fine I saw it
I'll take him by his word risk but I
will say this if he's not hurt then I
think she's just still getting used to
being back playing at this level this is
about his fourth or fifth game back
since that injury and Houston is going
at him like I've never seen anybody go
at one individual player before so I
think is that I think it's just a rush
along with just how relentless Houston
has been in attacking him yeah I made 23
times they made sure he was the primary
defender on on game to night and and
Game one they tried to do the same thing
to him too but he definitely played much
better in Game one I'm wondering how the
Warriors best you can tell are taking
that game to loss how are they taking
that one in Chris well I spoke with
Kevin Durant about what Houston is doing
we know when Stefan Stefan career Nick
young are on the court same time Dan
Houston has two options to go after to
try to get those pick switches and try
to exploit that and I asked coming
around what can you guys do from a team
defensive perspective because it pretty
much takes you guys out of it and leaves
it up to the individual to keep his man
in front he was like look he's like
Steph and everybody else just has to man
up instead this is he said this is old
school playground basketball we just got
to keep your man in front of you and
said we got to trust our teammates that
they're going to be able to get the job
done and rich you talk about those 23
possessions
look they tried to go out on more so
that that those twenty three possessions
don't take into account all the times
they're trying to pick and move stuff
around and he's like Steph is working
like he is moving his feet it's just
getting fatiguing because on some
occasions those picks do work and they
get stuff messed up on them and other
cases that still try to use him the man
that their garden full screen and Stefan
is moving all around so
he's washing down then what the numbers
even will indicate and so it's uh I
don't know what the water can do I don't
know if they say hey you know let's just
stop switching things and go under the
screens and if you do that then you're
leaving those armies the shooters open
so yeah it's going to be a tough
difficult task and adjustment for Steve
Kerr but I think everybody's looking for
what he's gonna do for Game three what
do you think he's going to do
Christine's state of course I think he's
gonna stay the course and keep switching
because like I said it's too problematic
when you start going under those screens
but I just think more guys are going to
have to help and then if you're helping
then you leave in the PGA chuckers and
several reasons open for those threes I
think they're just gonna try to bet that
those guys just don't dominate them like
they did in Game two you know they they
wanna they want to keep the ball out of
Chris Paul and James on his hands much
as possible so I would see a lot more
help defense and we'll think they were
trying to live with what PJ Tucker
versus those guys Chris Haynes here on
the Rich Eisen show from ESPN the one
thing that the Warriors have not
experienced in the playoffs with Durant
part of this group is obviously a
serious log that goes longer than five
games but in terms of the intangible
they've never in my mind experienced
doubt do you think that's possible to
place that into the equation in this
series Chris no I think it's possible I
don't I don't think they saw that right
now um you know I'll talk to draymond
Green after that game to boss it she was
like he's he told me you know
complacency could have you know dripped
in you know after they won that first
game and took home court evaluated he
said maybe maybe people were satisfied
and so there's no doubt I think they
feel like they'll be able to come home
and take care of those both games and go
back up go back to Houston up 3-1 but
look the way that Houston plays like
it's overwhelming like when they're off
they're off but when they're on I'm
talking about getting in transition
hitting all those threes Chris Paul
James Hart and break you down in
isolation says it really gets the more
aligned
and it really can have a mental effect
on a team like so where it's like it's
because it doesn't want to beat you
they're gonna blow you out that's just
how it used to plays so I can see if
they if one if you think it's one of
those games like that what a blow gonna
stay out at home B yes I think you can
see some doubt plant plant a factor for
the Warriors locker room but uh as a
right now there was no sense that they
feel that way right now but look this is
the series that everybody's been awake
before go to state has been looking
forward to this series because juice has
been talking trash all year and so you
never know but you know we definitely
shall see so Chris Haynes from ESPN
covering the Golden State Warriors
primarily here on the Rich Eisen show
one of the postgame 1 sound bites that
struck me Chris was when klay Thompson
was on the set with Shaq and Charles and
Kenny and an Ernie on Turner when they
ran the highlight package and there was
hardly any klay Thompson in it they had
some fun by saying to clay you know that
he's kind of the third fourth guy that
gets mentioned for this team and does he
mind it and he basically said he doesn't
he's handsomely paid he lives in the Bay
Area and he plays for Championships I'm
wondering where that attitude comes from
to prevent the Pat Riley disease of more
sinking in yeah I think clay is similar
to you know the personality of Tim
Duncan real low maintenance guy he you
know everybody has a ego but I don't
think his ego was anywhere close to the
star the other stars we have in this
league you know and that's a value in a
luxury for Golden State because um they
can they can use that to their advantage
as well and so I think clay understands
that he's in the ideal situation and
he's talked about it you know ever since
I've been you know covering his team
he's talked about the fact that he knows
that he's in a special situation and he
wants to try to maximize that to the
best of his ability and he's gonna have
a situation come up with his contract or
you know she can be extended to summer
there he has to weigh the pros and cons
of
doing that does he leave money on the
table or does he try to go out there and
chase the situation where he's the
marquee players so but like I said he's
similar to Tim Duncan so where I would
be surprised if he continues to make
sacrifices that keep this core together
is Steve Kerr instrumental in in
fostering that attitude not just with
the clay but everybody else I'm just
trying to see whether if there's any
secret sauce going on here no I think so
original question you brings up because
I know Steve are often talks about you
know those Chicago Bulls to needs you
know allowing greed to get here you know
and you know even though they were known
as a dynasty
you know they players on that team there
was those nineties bull teams believed
that they could have had more rings and
so I think certainly if if Steve Kerr is
you know harping on the you know just
about keeping continuity and keeping a
core together from all stretches I
definitely think that does play a part
I know they've had a conversation like
that before I don't think Steve is using
that to say hey guys I'll do all you can
to keep it together but yeah I think
definitely think what he's there's an
experience of being a part of something
similar I think that does weigh on the
guy's a couple of more minutes with
Chris Haynes of ESPN I want to pick your
brain about what you can tell me what
you think's going on in Cleveland right
now Tristan Thompson saying that if
you're not communicating on defense and
sit your ass on the bench who's he
talking about you know I would be I
would be surprised that if that's a
subtle shot on the block and LeBron -
that's one thing I always respect it
from TT is that we all know LeBron like
the bra he'll go off of anybody you know
he'll showing up on the court and I
noticed that whenever he does that the
TT sometimes here take it but sometimes
you stop it go right back off on the bra
why the cameras are rolling and I
haven't seen many players do that and so
I wouldn't be surprised that's a subtle
shot at LeBron but obviously
collectively they all need to do the
same thing and follow his lead and it's
interesting everything I cover that team
for two years
cup of the year they won that title and
it seemed like throughout the point
throughout the course of the season they
will always have their lunch and it'd be
lumps to where you feel like man they
need to practice this thing god they
either go out and just buy but at the
end of the day that towards the end of
the season the Cavaliers of make repairs
and they'll they'll get it going but
this season I haven't seen this before
this is a circus season there's been a
circus in the postseason and so I don't
know what I don't know what to say about
that squad oh they're you know they
definitely if they don't get game 3 you
know obviously it's over but I've never
seen this from a LeBron James team
especially LeBron James team since he's
came back to the Cavaliers well then he
must be sitting there in the back of his
head last one for you here Chris is how
the next few games plays out plays into
his decision on July 1st how can you
read those tea leaves for me best you
can right now I personally I personally
believe that his mind is probably
already made up yeah I know life a lot
of people will disagree with that and
say he's not gonna make the decision
till after I think his mind is pretty
much all made up all no not where he's
gonna go but you know that it's hard for
me to see him back in Cleveland race
that's that's just it and I think even
if he is able to I don't know if he's
able to get past Boston uh uh it's
difficult to see it but if he's able to
do that huh I just don't see him at that
team matching up well against going to
state or the Rockets yeah ultimately for
LeBron it's all about Championships so
if he doesn't if you feel he doesn't
have the luster that can compete for a
title and not just compete you know when
the damn thing ah he he's not going to
be invested and so I I think his mind
may be made up as far as you know that
you know as far as that he's leaving
Cleveland so this games really don't
matter a grand scope of things but I
definitely done the one part that plays
in the favor of the Cavs is that there
are a lot of teams out there whoops cap
space and with the situation that's
desirable for LeBron
so they had that
but look uh I think it's ultimately
going to hand with LeBron taking off
where I don't know but you know
definitely the way they're ending this
this postseason or appear to be ending
this postseason is definitely not going
to bode well for the calf that's what we
call a cliffhanger and that's why I love
having your on Chris I look forward to
chatting before the finals that's for
sure no doubt rich rich always thanks
for happening always absolutely Chris
Haynes Chris B Haynes the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience